si j'avais à dire de façon imagée là
c'est quelqu'un qui rentrait chez nous
la cagoule et pour faire du grabuge
appel à la police
je peins tolérable a pas de cause qui
peut ou on peut tolérer que des gens
masqués comme est dévoré de paix nous ne
tolèrerons aucune limitation aucune
forme de llodra nous nous appuyons il
nous sommes confiants que votre
université se relèvera de l'affront que
quelques individus sinistre lui ont fait
subir
donc on le voit le gouvernement
couillard a réitéré son appui
inconditionnel au recteur de l'uqam
aujourd'hui dans le dossier étudiants
mais doit-il en faire plus pour empêcher
que ce conflit ne s'envenime davantage
d'achats et à québec ce soir daniel et à
ottawa michel et à montréal bonsoir à
vous trois tasha que doit faire le
gouvernement à la méthode douce la
méthode dure négocier ne pas négocier
je vois mal céline sur quoi ils doivent
négocier dans ce cas si elle et
d'étudiants réclament quelque chose que
le gouvernement peut pas leur donner
c'est à dire que changer complètement la
direction de l'austérité et changer le
budget
écoutez c'est très malheureux ce qui se
passe à l'uqam très malheureux mais la
violence est inacceptable et les
cagoules aussi et c'est l'intimidation
et je vois que les autres étudiants ne
veux pas embarquer dans la situation les
étudiants qui veulent faire leurs
courses et injuste
hier est ce qu'apple johnny étudiants en
grève la sueur oui obtient environ un
tiers qui sont en grève et le reste le
sont pas et je trouve que le
gouvernement doit être ferme et que les
étudiants s'ils veulent faire valoir
leur leur demande s'ils vont dans la rue
et font des manifestations mais pas
perturber les cours
michel we pour perturber les cours mais
pas saccager l'université non plus je
comprends comment il ya une vieille
tradition de devoir d'université comme
espèce de sanctuaires le kit à l'abri de
toutes les influences mais écoutez ce
sanctuaire doit d'avoir un bien public
l'heure on paye pour ça
et à tous égards inacceptable maintenant
la voie de sortie est vraiment pas
évident parce que voyez ceux qui disent
comme l'opposition péquiste par exemple
on voudrait encadrer le droit de grève
d'une part je pas certain que c'est le
voeu des gens de là c'est actuellement
parce que si le droit de grève est
encadré s'il fallait prendre des votes
secrets
il est loin d'être certain que la grèce
continuerait et d'autre part c'est pas
c'est pas une solution pour une crise
immédiate
si on voulait légiférer là dessus ça va
prendre des semaines sinon des mois
voire une commission parlementaire alors
la spa dispose sortie de crise là je
pense que le gouvernement ne veut pas
envoyer la sqs de toute évidence mais je
pense que là la solution va venir
éventuellement des étudiants eux mêmes
qui vont continuer à prendre des votes
et j'ai l'impression que le mouvement va
s'essouffler mais le gouvernement ne
peut pas d'aucune façon ne pas faire
respecter les injonctions il est quand
même deux gardiens de la loi
ouais mais en même temps daniel est ce
que cette crise-là l'uqam peut se régler
à coup d'injections justement non c'est
jamais la meilleure façon de régler une
crise yahia aucun doute là dessus si on
peut le faire par la négociation comme
le suggérait géré à la rose plutôt avec
notre collègue anne marie dussault ce
serait sûrement l'idéal ce que les
étudiants avaient négocié qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent exactement qu'est ce
qu'ils prévoient comme sortie de crise
ce n'est pas évident mais l'injonction
ce n'est jamais la bonne solution
le recours à la police non plus sauf que
quand des crimes sont commis comme ça a
été le cas hier soir vous n'avez pas le
choix comme michel de 10 ce n'est pas un
sanctuaire dans plusieurs universités
canadiennes il ya eu récemment des cas
de violences sexuelles à l'endroit de
femmes
on a fait la police quand des équipes
sportives dérape dans les universités on
appelle la police
halifax quand les étudiants en médecine
ont fait ce site web absolument haineux
à l'endroit des femmes
on a appelé la police fait quoi du cam
si le feu prend 2 n'appelle pas les
pompiers mais pour éviter d'en arriver
là si aurait pas fallu quand même tiré
certaines leçons de 2012 d'achat parce
que on parle quand michel disait
c'est peut-être pas le moment de parler
du droit de grève avec cette erreur mais
quand même il y avait des leçons à tirer
qui ne le sont les quelles leçons la
leçon à tirer c'est que on doit
respecter aussi les droits des étudiants
et les gens en fonction qui sont là les
étudiants qui ne veulent pas participer
à cette grève et c'est différent c'est
très différent de 2012 mettre des
cagoules et aller dans les universités
comme ça faire l'intimidation oui il y
en avait mais c'était pas à ce point-ci
ici aussi il ya paul des négociations
possibles parce qu'il n'y a pas de
demande spécifique et c'est pour ça que
moi je doute fortement que c'est tous
des étudiants ça me rappelle un peu de
ce qui s'est passé à toronto lors de
l'assemblée du g8 où on avait des
anarchistes qui sont d'aller dans la rue
perturber les démonstrations légitime
avec de la violence et je crains que
c'est cette sorte de situation on sait
aussi qu'ils sont ces masques là alors
c'est très difficile on peut pas
négocier avec des gens qui sont violents
michel quand même il y avait le rapport
de la commission ménard avait recommandé
de d'encadrer le droit de grève des
étudiants
le gouvernement aujourd'hui disait c'est
pas l'enjeu dont il est question en ce
moment et il ne semble pas vouloir le
reconnaître mais est-ce que c'est quand
même pas au coeur de 2,6 de ce produit
du problème en ce moment il y aurait
fallu agir en amont si je peux dire il
certain que si sa droite grève
l'ad'abord avaient été définis qu'on
avait prévu des règles de votre secret
de cette erreur de de quorum il y aurait
probablement pas de grève l'actuellement
passe la majorité à voter voter qu'on
dit maintenant le rapport ménard la
façon dont il avait été présenté par le
gouvernement de pauline marois dès le
départ c'est à dire comme une espèce de
procèder la gestion de la crise de 2012
cependant par le gouvernement charest
donnait pas beaucoup envie aux libéraux
de lui donner quelques tweets que ce
soit mais
vous souviendrez aussi qu'en 2013 les
u11 sommet de l'éducation à l'occasion
duquel on aurait très bien pu ouvrir un
chantier sur la démocratie étudiante
dans toutes ses facettes et le
gouvernement de pauline marois n'a pas
voulu l'ouvrir alors les péquistes sont
un peu mal placé aujourd'hui pour dire
que c'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
qu'est-ce qui fait si peur au
gouvernement d'ouvrir ce dossier là
daniel s'est donné le droit de grève à
des étudiants qui le demandent pas
formellement tout corp en ce moment
l'encadré prévoir des sanctions comme
peu ça se passe chez les syndicats je
suis pas certain que c'est la bonne
solution je suis pas certain que les
étudiants c'est vraiment ça qui veulent
des étudiants au doigt de descendre dans
la rue ont le droit de protester de sa
société dans laquelle ils vivent ce sera
la société le lendemain qu'il de temps
en temps fasse du bruit que de temps en
temps un casse la gueule de quelqu'un on
peut tous vivre avec son milieu des
règles de démocratie qui ne respectent
pas toujours mais qu'ils se mobilisent
rosie souvent à ismaël de rien ça les
intérêts sport voyez les efforts
désespérés que fait le pq bon mobiliser
des jeunes qui se mobilisent qu'ils
s'impliquent on est tous d'accord avec
lui mais il ya des règles élémentaires à
suivre dans la société dans laquelle ils
ont choisi
je pense aussi que le fait qu'il ne
respecte pas les injonctions
pourquoi est ce qu'on pense qu'il
respecterait l'encadrement de grève ça
aussi ça nuit à cet argument là c'est
clairement des gens qui n'ont pas
intérêt à respecter des balises quoi que
ce soit des balises de la loi ou autre
alors comment on va sortir de l'impasse
michel bassez c'est la question à
s'améliorer nettement quand je vous dis
moi je pense que il faut que vous avez
la bonne réponse aux horizons à galway
j'aimerais évidemment non mais là je
pense qu'on n'a pas le choix que de
faire respecter les injonctions et je
pense que mais combien ça c'est aussi la
réputation l'université qui nageait ça
c'est autre chose je comprends qu'elle
recteur lui qui a déjà acté la
réputation de l'udc en a été pas mal
amoché cours des dernières années
souvenez-vous du fiasco de
l'îlot voyageur mais l'a écouté ce après
des années et des décennies je dirais
affaires de l'université du québec de
l'uqam université honorable su peu dire
qu'ils n'étaient pas universités
considérés comme de deuxième classe
comme elle l'était au moment de sa
formation
merci qui rend des services énormes en
particulier dans l'éducation des adultes
alors c'est très dommage de devoir cette
réputation la mâcher qui va vouloir
aller étudier à l'uqam c'est le bordel
tout temps mais pour ce qui est de la
sortie de crise
honnêtement je pense qu'il va falloir
que les étudiants y mettent du leur
ouais et c'est super mais tu sais tu
n'en faut il faut il faut il faut pas
croire que c'est une crise que le québec
est à feu et à sang c'est l'impression
que donnait les médias aujourd'hui
mais c'est une triste très très très
très localisé à montréal autour d'une
institution peut être deux si vous
ajoutez le cégep du vieux montréal mme
autour d'une institution pour la crise
du québec c'est quoi la crise des
étudiants du québec
c'est la crise de l'uqam et c'est pour
ça que ça demande des solutions qui
appliquent déjà du cames et le
gouvernement a peut-être très bien alors
passons à l'autre sujet aujourd'hui on a
appris cette semaine que le député de la
caq gérald deltell quitter son poste de
député pour se présenter dans comté de
louis saint laurent pour le parti
conservateur il ya d'autres noms aussi
un rs le maire de victoriaville qui
devrait annoncer qu'il fait le saut il
ya l'ex journaliste pascal terry elle
qui se présentent dans mont-royal pour
les conservateurs et daniel vous me
disiez on apprend ce soir d'un collègue
jean lapierre que lawrence cannon peut
être viendrez pour se présenter à la
prochaine élection
ce circule depuis un bon bout de temps
chez les messieurs cas ne jamais
vraiment des démentis a souri par
éthique contre lui on en parle trouve
qu'il a envie et ce serait pour les
conservateurs une excellente pré
sélectionné un retour qui donnerait
beaucoup de crédibilité à cette équipe
qui n'est pas très très fort disons là à
l'arrivée de gérard deltell aussi c'est
une bonne prise pour les conservateurs
ce n'est pas l'unanimité à québec mais
mais les conservateurs qui vont pour
envoyer une très mauvaise expression
mettre le paquet dans une vingtaine de
circonscriptions met plein d'argent
peine d'organisation tous les moyens ce
genre de candidats qui vont tenter de
recruter quand même qu est ce que ça
nous dit du parti conservateur de sa
stratégie au québec
d'attirer de ce genre de candidates
achats je pense que écoute les
conservateurs je pense un intérêt à
maintenir la force de façon ironique de
la paix d ici au québec en grande
majorité parce qu'ils veulent pas que
les libéraux font des gains en même
temps ils peuvent pas être pris à peu
prendre le québec au sérieux et ils
aimeraient avoir des candidats vedettes
aussi à mettre dans la vitrine
on voit que mont royal par exemple c'est
un compte et que les conservateurs ne
volent très grande chance ils n'ont plus
jamais performer très bien là bas mais
mettre une candidate vedette ça veut
dire qu'ils peuvent recevoir une
certaine respectabilité une certaine
notoriété dans les médias aussi
alors c'est une façon d'attirer de la
tension mais en même temps s'assurer que
il ne faut pas peut-être trop nuire à la
machine npd on veut que l'interdire
revient devient fort mauvais sport au
québec les conservateurs
oui mais nulle part ailleurs au canada
et parce qu'autrement ces libéraux
contrôle de gains ici ça va ça va me
donner la possibilité qui forme le
prochain gouvernement s'ils n'en font
pas même s'ils font un bon score en
ontario c'est que douteux michel parlant
de gérard deltell est ce que ça peu son
départ est ce que ça peut faire mal à la
casse non non c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour pour laquelle dans la
région québec à tout le moins monsieur
deltell était connue et très appréciée
c'est moins dramatique si vous voulez
depuis l'élection de françois paradis
dans les vies pas très connu à montréal
de ce paradigme à québec c'était une
grosse vedette de la radio adam il ya
quand même maintenant une autre figure
de proue qui peut qui peut porter
l'étendard de la caq dans la région de
québec
maintenant pour revenir à ce que vous
vous demandiez comme question c'est
qu'est ce que ça nous dit sur la
stratégie des conservateurs je pense
qu'une des choses qu'on peut retenir
c'est que les conservateurs comptent sur
des noms connus et non pop sur ses
politiques pour faire du
du millage au québec et on sait très
bien la boxe les politiques
conservatrices ne plaisent pas à dijon
la majorité de la population il ya des
conservateurs au québec mais c'est pas
l'interdiction la destruction du du
registre des armes à feu ou le refus de
négocier le l'abolition du péage sur le
champ de pont champlain qui va leur
permettre de faire beaucoup de bien
alors on se dit les ces gens devront
peut-être attirer des votes parce que ce
sont des vedettes
malgré nos politiques qui déplaisent la
population il y avait une rumeur qui a
couru à québec une petite rumeur que
peut-être que ça voulait dire que avec
ces candidats qui qui arrivent elles à
six mois avant les élections que ça
pouvait vouloir dire des élections
anticipées c'est possible ça tasha je
vous vois sourire
moi je vais passer pendant longtemps que
les conservateurs auraient eu intérêt à
aller à oseo au printemps et je pense
qu'il y avait une fenêtre vous aurez pu
faire ça mais maintenant je pense qu'ils
vont attendre ils voient que le procès
de mcdo fille vient de commencer je
pense qu'il regarde cela avec un oeil
ces traîtres cerner il veut savoir si ça
va avoir deux attaques pendant tout
est-ce que ça va s'estomper pendant
l'été toute cette affaire et je pense
que si ces cas et adhèrent à ces trois
jours et c'est excitant peut-être pour
les politologues je sais pas pour les la
personne moyenne dans la rue c'est
regarde ça si proches que ça mais je
pense qu'ils vont attendre qu'une ans
daniel voisine oui à cheveuges fait des
prédictions je me trouve alors s'il dit
qu'il va y avoir des élections ce
printemps il ya de repos je vous ai rien
je vous ai simplement de bien vous
rappeler que des élections dans l'île du
prince édouard mais surtout en alberta
mais et l'alberta jim prentice qui
devait balayer la province un client
mais moins certain en ce moment alors
s'ils verront plus haut peut-être
vouloir voir un peu comment ça se passe
dans ces deux provinces avant de avant
d'aller à la pêche que je pense qu'il va
attendre à l'automne même si la pêche
moins bonne
michel rapidement quelques secondes oui
non il anticipe maintenant moi je pense
que les élections vont avoir lieu à la
date prévue j'ai jamais cru honnêtement
au scénario d'élections précipitées
je crois encore moins attendre
résultat du la façon dont le procès de
suivre vont tourner de toute manière on
va être rendue à la période prévue très
bien merci beaucoup à vous trois
pourquoi semaine prochaine au revoir